we all like to imagine that our favorite
actors and actresses are great people in
real life sure they might play a jerk on
screen once in a while but that's just
acting right it's what they do well with
great Fame comes great entitlement and
some of Hollywood's finest are just
plain nasty at times each of these
actors have earned a bad rep for the way
they behave between takes be it talking
down to craft services warring with
co-stars or fighting with directors
maybe they were all just having a bad
day over and over again again and again
and again and again and again here are a
few of the big-name actors people hate
working with Val Kilmer at this point
Val Kilmer's reputation precedes him
as far as acting jerks go Val Kilmer is
right at the top of the list starting
all the way back in 1995 with Batman
Forever Kilmer has been known for his
attitude when the cameras aren't rolling
after production director Joel
Schumacher said in an interview that Val
Kilmer was childish and impossible but
his words were hardly the last we hear
of Kilmer stuff - after the island of
dr. Moreau hit theatres the very next
year director John Frankenheimer
famously said quote I will never climb
Mount Everest and I will never work with
Val Kilmer again end quote
meanwhile one of the movie's actors Neil
Young had this to say about his antics
he was just kind of being a bit rude and
abrasive he that was his character
though so fair go maybe that was the way
he prepared to be - you know act like
one off camera noticing a pattern here
Alec Baldwin
there is no doubting that Alec Baldwin
is an outspoken man whether he's being
accused of fighting paparazzi shouting
homophobic slurs or calling his own
daughter names and a leaked voicemail
his private life has a way of being
shoved into the limelight on a regular
basis as a number of his co-stars have
said that's just who he is
Shia LaBeouf who's had no shortage of
conflicts all his own more on that in a
minute
famously left the Broadway show orphans
in 2013 because the two actors had
clashed so often at rehearsals and on 30
rock his co-star Cheyenne Jackson has
one thing to say about Baldwin quotes
what I learned from him was really good
comedic timing and don't get in his
light and quote Shia LaBeouf
for a guy who got his start playing the
adorable lead in Disney's even Stephens
Shia LaBeouf sure has shed any
presumption of innocence in the years
since LaBeouf made his way to the big
screen in a big way shortly after the
show ended with major blockbusters like
Constantine iRobot and of course the
Transformers franchise which kicked his
career straight into the stratosphere
after he reached such great heights
though things changed very quickly and
bizarrely Shia started taking more
avant-garde roles and staged a bunch of
strange publicity stunts like wearing a
paper bag that said I am NOT famous
anymore and filming himself watching all
of his own movies in a row clearly he
wanted the world to take him seriously
but his penchant for weird antics and
over-the-top method acting has begun to
rub people the wrong way he's even
gotten into fistfights with at least two
of his co-stars with Tom Hardy on the
set of 2012's lawless and again after
punching Brad Pitt on 2014's war epic
fury in both cases his co-stars let it
slide where the public was concerned
because shiz got this weird little left
uppercut you got to stay away from you
got to watch that one but the production
on lawless also saw the buff guzzling
actual bottles of moonshine to get into
character and carving his name into Mia
Vecchi coughs cos dressing-room door
LaBeouf might not want to be famous
anymore but he's quickly becoming
infamous what does that mean in famous
famous is when you're more than famous
hmm not quite but that reminds us Chevy
Chase his character history might read
like a who's who and likeable goofs but
Chevy Chase has something of a
reputation as one of the meanest men in
showbiz that rep has followed him all
the way from his Rockstar beginnings on
Saturday Night Live in the 70s up to his
recent recurring gig on community
highlights from his worst moments
include getting into a fistfight with
Bill Murray and suggesting that former
SNL co-star Terry Sweeney who was openly
gay do a weekly segment where he would
get Wade
see if he had contracted AIDS yet oh hi
fellas it certainly seems like Chevy
Chase has a penchant for rubbing people
the wrong way he even came clean about
it in 2012 when he said quote nobody
prepares you for what happens when you
get famous and I didn't handle it well
end quote
that may be the understatement of the
decade Mandy Patinkin
he might not quite be a household name
but you probably know his work from his
unforgettable role in 1987's The
Princess Bride
my name is inigo montoya
you killed my father prepare to die more
recently you may have seen him in CBS's
criminal minds and the Golden Globe
winning Showtime series homeland with so
much success in film and television
people probably suspect that Mandy
Patinkin is a pretty nice guy but by his
own admission he can be extremely
difficult to work with
before nearly destroying his television
career in 2007 by suddenly walking away
from Criminal Minds and never coming
back Potemkin was already behaving like
a stuck-up starlet in a 2013 interview
with the New York Times he came clean
with his sordid past on the set talking
about the hospital drama Chicago Hope
Patinkin said quote I never let
directors talk to me because I was so
spoiled I was saying don't talk to me I
don't want your opinion I behaved
abominably and quote hey at least he can
admit it Mike Myers it's almost a cliche
now that comedians often have darker
sides and Mike Myers is an immune to the
pressures of being a full-time funny man
between Wayne's World Austin Powers and
The Love Guru Myers whole brand is
over-the-top outrageously colorful
characters most of whom he's
meticulously crafted himself throw me a
frickin bone here he's been called a
perfectionist on his good days and on
his worst he's been dubbed emotionally
needy and difficult that
characterization comes directly from
Penelope Spheeris who directed Mike
Myers in 1992 s Wayne's World spyro's
also told the story of how Mike Myers
stormed off the set once because the
caterers didn't provide margarine for
his bagel kissed your mother with that
mouth
Gwyneth Paltrow it's easy enough for the
internet to hate Gwyneth Paltrow who's
managed to outrage non millionaire
parents everywhere with her lifestyle
blog goop and has an unfortunate
tendency to come across as aloof and
entitled as we here also often Paltrow
is just one of those everyday moms the
kind who allegedly refuses to touch
other people's shower water at her gym
and won't use toilet paper if the role
is already unwrapped so yeah her
apparently uptight mannerisms have
earned her a starring role as a punching
bag for celebrity gossip but she's also
difficult to work with four other
a-listers too according to reports from
the set of 2010 si
man to Paltrow made it a point to avoid
her co-star Scarlett Johansson during
the whole production and then got angry
when she was upstaged by Johansson
during the promotional work for the film
of course one of her press
representatives denied those claims so
it's possible that the story was simply
another piece of trumped up gossip but
when it comes to madam goop
who can tell Katherine Heigl few people
have become the target of tabloid fodder
as completely as Katherine Heigl in 2008
she publicly bashed her comedy breakout
film knocked up as sexist and she also
famously declined to be considered for
the Emmys because she thought the Grey's
Anatomy writers didn't give her enough
juicy dramatic material to deserve a
nomination the series creator Shonda
Rhimes
said afterward of the situation yeah on
some on some level of song and on some
level I was not surprised you weren't
know okay when people show you who they
are believe them Rhimes reportedly
declined an offer for Heigl to return to
the show after her character's departure
Patrick Dempsey Katherine Heigl wasn't
the only real-life pill on the set of
Grey's either Patrick Dempsey better
known as McDreamy was also apparently
suspended once for acting like a diva on
set and was killed off on the show not
long after that Dempsey had reportedly
clashed with Shonda Rhimes while he
later denied that there was anything but
goodwill between him and the cast that
story has since been hard to shake Bruce
Willis you may remember the time Kevin
Smith described Bruce Willis as [ __ ]
soul-crushing to work with after teaming
with him for 2010's cop out according to
Smith Bruce Willis was pretty much his
hero until he actually worked with the
guy meanwhile tears of the Sun director
Antoine Fuqua called Bruce Willis a
major pain in the ass to work with and
sylvester stallone seem to have similar
issues with bruce willis during the
expendable series he dropped willis for
Harrison Ford and Expendables 3 and
immediately after announcing the switch
he tweeted a vague possible stab at
Willis that read quote greedy and lazy
Asher formula for career failure end
quote
Teri Hatcher Desperate Housewives was as
dramatic behind the scenes as it was for
at-home audiences the hot ABC show had
trouble from the start and actress teri
hatcher who played
Susan apparently took the brunt of the
criticism from her cast mates who felt
she acted like a diva Hatcher's co-star
Nicollette Sheridan went so far as to
call her the meanest woman in the world
after the final episode of Desperate
Housewives
Hatcher reportedly stated quote I will
never disclose the true and complicated
journey of assault and quote it's
probably just as well some questions are
probably best left unanswered Stephen
Segal this action star was basically
born to raise hell and while he's no
longer headlining big-budget features
Stephen Segal is still churning out
low-budget films left and right even
though he's developed a reputation for
not being the best dude around Stephen
Segal has been hit with countless
allegations of sexual assaults among
other charges over the years including
one by under siege to auditioner Jenny
McCarthy who said in an interview that
Seagal told her to take off her dress
during a private audition despite the
absence of nudity in the film yuk he's
also been known to flex some of his
silver screen might on his male co-stars
when the cameras weren't rolling John
Leguizamo reportedly claimed that Seagal
elbows him up against a wall with
maximum conviction on the set of 1996
'as executive decision simply because
Leguizamo laughed at something Segal
said thinking it was a joke when it
wasn't and he came up and he he
Taekwondo my ass against a brick wall
when he's six foot five and caught me
off guard knocked thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our youtube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you love to